bonjour stéphane cauchy merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france pour parler de joux des
problèmes des professionnels de la route
que vous représentez il y à il y a des
difficultés est évidemment liée à la
hausse du prix des carburants des péages
mais également des assurances expliquez
nous pourquoi
eh bien nous avons effectivement elle
des difficultés que nous rencontrons
depuis maintenant plus d'un an avec des
augmentations régulières sur vous dit
effectivement le prix des assurances le
prix du gazole le prix des camions ça
devient toutes ces augmentations
devienne insupportable pour nos
transporteurs puisque nous avons
aujourd'hui une part des clients qui
refusent de pouvoir répercuter ces
augmentations prix et donc comme vous
l'avez dit dans votre sujet
juste avant nous risquons d'avoir des
défaillances d'entreprises
durant cette année c'est évident ça
concerne les révéler les transporteurs
routiers mais également les taxis et les
ambulanciers je ne sais pas d'où elle
est exportée routier les transporteurs
routiers tous ceux qui utilisent je
dirais la route les carburants les
ambulanciers les transporteurs de le
transport de voyageurs l'écart les bus
alors que demandez vous conte cali et
utilise tous les utilisateurs de la
route aujourd'hui suivi cette
augmentation du prix des énergies 30 à
40 % d'augmentation sur un an sur le sur
le gazole vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
400 % d'augmentation sur le gaz par
exemple les entrées les entreprises de
transport qui ont joué le jeu de la
transition écologique en investissant
dans des thèmes langage est ce qu'on
nous avait dit la non polluant moins
polluants et plus économes aujourd'hui
se retrouve en très grande difficulté
avec une augmentation de 400% des
énergies gaz ou alors on a vu le
collègue au gouvernement a octroyé un
chèque énergie aux ménages d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas suffisant dit la cour des
comptes vous pensez qu si il aurait dû
penser le gouvernement au bout aux
professionnels de santé de transport par
destot demain
alors ce qui est important pour nous en
fait il existe aujourd'hui un mécanisme
légal d'indexation gazole sur le jeu par
le niveau d énergie au niveau du
transport routier les ambulanciers n'ont
pas ce
set cet avantage mais bon on a
les transporteurs aujourd'hui avec cette
indexation ce qu'on appelle le cas de
factures doivent répercuter la variation
du coût du gazole sur sur le prix du
transport aujourd'hui nous avons des
clients qui refusent l'application de
cette de cette indexation ce fondement
nouveau gouvernement c'est justement
d'avoir le de permettre par un
renforcement je dirais des dés
comment dire des contrôles auprès des
entreprises sur le respect de cette
cette disposition légale elle existe
depuis 2006 et on a encore aujourd'hui
des clients qui refusent l'application
de cette de cette disposition légale qui
nous permettraient je dirais de pouvoir
amortir ces augmentations de cours or
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande sur nice de
l'économie et notre ministre de tutelle
de pouvoir justement avoir des
renforcements par les services de la
dgccrf par exemple des contrôles auprès
des entreprises qui sont récalcitrants
tu à l'application de cette disposition
légale on met ces contrôles ça va
prendre du temps vous voulez admettez
mais c'est la seule solution
alors c'est la seule solution on a
aujourd'hui aussi des entreprises on a
je dirai au niveau du coût du gazole on
a au niveau de la fiscalité un
remboursement partiel de la tpe pour le
pourrai je dirais appelé à un gazole
professionnel ce qu'on souhaiterait nous
c'est que cette ce remboursement
légal enfin ce remboursement partiel de
la tcp eu d'une part des taxes et du
gazole soit fait directement à la pompe
par exemple ça aiderait aussi ça
permettrait aux entreprises qui
subissent d'autres augmentations parce
qu'à part que les augmentations du gazon
avant l'unité tout à l'heure ça
permettrait de maintenir les trésoreries
nos entreprises qui sont en grande
difficulté aujourd'hui oui la vie dans
le risque de faillite est bien réelle
elle dit oui pardon le risque de bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr on a déjà des
entreprises de transport aujourd'hui qui
dépose le bilan pourquoi tout simplement
parce qu'elles n'ont pas la possibilité
de répercuter l'augmentation des coûts
du transport vers a juste pris auprès de
leurs clients alors il faut savoir que
la relation elle est biaisé
aujourd'hui dans le la relation avec
avec nos clients pourquoi un jour je
vous rappelle que 80% des entreprises de
transport sont des tpe pme de moins de
50 salariés et on se retrouve dans des
négociations avec des entreprises de
taille industrielle qui en grande partie
refuse d'appliquer ces augmentations
on a 30 à 40 % d'augmentation ni viateur
ses 20% sur les augmentations des prix
des camions les pneus et là des blue la
maintenance les pièces détachées et on
vient d'avoir les augmentation des
péages autoroutiers
il est important pour nous de pouvoir
répercuter ces prix auprès de nos
clients et aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible les clients refusent enfin pas
tous bien évidemment vers être une
grande partie est ici on ne l'interdît
pas enfin si on ne fait rien si nous
2010 par exemple ne
pas ne renforce pas les contrôles ou ne
veuille pas à une relation saine au
niveau des
des clients
on aura effectivement des défaillances
on a déjà des entreprises de transport
qui ont arrêté des camions qui ont
également sur parking parce que c'était
plus rentables on ne gagne plus d'argent
à faire rouler des camions est-ce que
vous avez été le prix pardon est ce que
votre appel à la réalité entendu là pour
l'instant on n'a pas de on n'a pas
beaucoup d'échos de la part de nos
ministres
j'espère que ça va changer donc on aura
au moins un accompagnement les prix
abusivement pas aujourd'hui son peters
et dans l'affrètement notamment puisque
dans l'affrètement lorsque vous êtes
affrétés il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui refusent d'appliquer ses pieds de
factures d'appliquer je dirais le juste
prix et donc on demande nous aujourd'hui
de pouvoir avoir un prix normal les
marges des entreprises de transport ca à
2% là le cumul de toutes ces
augmentations
ces 5 c allez on va dire entre 5 et 10%
et encore je suis je suis juste c'est
entre 5 et 10% lorsque vous avez je
dirais des démarches de 1 2% et vous
subissez des augmentations de 5 à 10 %
ce qui représente 5 à 10 % sur le prix
du transport vous êtes vous c'est pas
compliqué de comprendre qu'à la fin de
l'année il y aura énormément de
défaillance maîtrisée durée de transport
puisque on m'a arrêté des camions voilà
tout simplement merci beaucoup stéphane
cauchy pour toutes ces précisions plus
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans la matinale